take that arsonist we are live here on
fox square
for a reason as you know yesterday a
cowardly christmas creep burned down our
all-american christmas tree we put the
tree up outside of our building not for
ourselves but for all of you the nypd
and the fdny arrived at the scene
quickly to put out the flames and made
sure everyone was safe at a time when
law enforcement is constantly criticized
and disrespected we are once again shown
how important their work really is and
we're grateful for their service
[Applause]
we want to take this moment now to give
a special shout out to the officers and
quick who quickly apprehended the
suspect they are actually here tonight
to join us in the relighting we're also
joined by members of the fdny i speak it
for everyone here when i say thank you
for all your sacrifices to keep us safe
and even though the arsonist is already
out on the streets
probably working at cnn
we want the bad guys to know that you
can keep burning down our trees because
we're just going to keep putting up
another one
because that's the real holiday spirit
jesse all right thanks craig
fox wanted to create a space where
people from all over could come together
without fear and celebrate this joyous
holiday season because when you take
away all the parties and all the
presents and all the decorations
what really matters what are we left
with
the answer is simple
look around you
it's the people that truly make this
time of year special
[Applause]
and when our beautiful tree was burnt
down by a repeat offender arsonist we
knew that we couldn't let it stop us we
knew that we wouldn't be deterred and we
were determined to rebuild so memories
could once again be made right here on
fox square
and
and rebuild we did in record time
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight as we relight the all-american
christmas tree we are joined by fox news
talent and executives along with members
of the nypd and the fdny timothy
cardinal dolan fdny chaplain rabbi
joseph potassnik and fox news
contributor reverend jacques de graaf
are also here and will share remarks in
a moment we are so grateful for the
overwhelming support from our viewers
corporate colleagues right here in
midtown manhattan and our fellow fox
employees thanks to the hard work of so
many including the american christmas
company we are now standing in front of
a brand new tree
yes that's right
this holiday season serves as a reminder
that at the end of the day there will
always be more that unites us than
divides us and before we light this new
tree as a silver lining and an act of
kindness during the holiday season both
fox news media and fox corporation have
made a 100 000 donation to answer the
call which provides financial assistance
to the families of fallen service
members of the nypd and fdny the two
agencies who responded immediately to
our very own emergency so thank you to
fox for doing that indeed i mean it's
amazing we can be here
nobody stopped working for the last 36
hours to make this happen yeah fox
really knows how to bounce back don't we
yeah
i think i think we got to thank dana and
the fellow elves
you're welcome build back up that tree
feel back better than christmas trees
this actually works you're not that much
shorter than she is greg
i am in heels though in his defense yes
so am i at by the way
you will be later no but seriously
thanks to all the technical staff and
the producers of the five you guys did a
great job and it's a real honor to host
this relighting
and we're just very also thankful for
the security team that tackled this punk
and the
firefighters who put out the blaze very
very quickly and the police that showed
up immediately thank you guys very much
yeah thank you
and thank you to all of you for coming
out there are a lot of people
here so welcome to fox square
what do you think janine i think i think
it's great and here's the bottom line
we are united in enjoying this christmas
holiday together and we won't give up it
doesn't matter what they do to us
there you go there you go indeed all
right we now want to welcome our first
guest of the evening fox news
contributor reverend jacques du graf
somebody asked me why are you here
i'm here because these colors don't run
80 years ago this week
they tried to extinguish the darkness at
a place called pearl harbor
we didn't fold then
and we won't fall now because we've come
this far
by faith
in our tradition we say this little
light of mine
i'm gonna let it shine
the red the white the blue and the light
of america we're going to let it shine
[Music]
and so
we go to the throne of grace together
our father and our god the god of
abraham isaac and jacob
we come before your throne as humbly as
we know how to say
thank you
we remember the reason for the season
and our faith
we have a faith that the fire could not
incinerate
we have a faith that bullies cannot
frighten away we have a faith that
madmen cannot terrorize us on
we come to say thank you and merry
christmas we ask that you would bless
the greatest country on the planet
we ask that you would keep us and bless
us and god bless america and together
the best is yet to come and the men and
the women who love god said amen and the
men and the women who love god sad
and the men and the women who love god
sad
[Applause]
thank you reverend also with us today is
fdny chaplain rabbi joseph potassnik
thank
you i'm here
your eminence reverend i'm here for
diversity
i want to say to everyone here
the words united and untied are spelled
with the exact same letters we're here
to stand together because we live in the
united states of america not the untied
states of america
i said to
frank siller of the silver foundation
tunnel to towers shortly after 9 11 we
observed hanukkah and christmas at
ground zero the christmas tree arrived
20 feet high the hanukkah manor arrived
nine feet high a group of carpenters all
of whom were christian
volunteered to build a platform so that
the hanukkah menorah and the christmas
tree would be of the exact same height
we live in a country where hanukkah and
christmas can stand together as equal
partners and i'm here to say that an act
against christianity is an act against
judaism
we are united we are not untied
so
you have christmas we have hanukkah you
have easter we have passover together
united
we have thanksgiving we are thankful
that we live in a country where we can
believe in different faiths but we can
belong to one family i'm in amen
amen
thank you rabbi and now we welcome
timothy dolan the cardinal cardinal
timothy dolden
[Music]
folks i i got the high honor an honor
for which i'm very grateful of blessing
the new tree so you're ready let us pray
lord our god we praise you for the light
of creation the sun the moon and the
stars of the night we praise you for the
light of israel the law the prophets and
the wisdom of the scriptures
we praise you for jesus christ your son
he is emmanuel god with us the prince of
peace who fills us with the wonder of
your love
lord our god let your blessing come upon
us as we soon illumine this tree may the
light and cheer it gives be a sign of
the joy that fills our hearts may all
who delight in his tree come to the
knowledge and joy of salvation we ask
this through christ our lord amen amen
hallelujah blessed christmas all right
amen there you go
thank you cardinal dolan
jesse all right so let's go talk to some
people here
cardinal
i haven't seen you since confession
[Laughter]
that was on fire
[Laughter]
so what is the symbolism in your opinion
of a re-lighting of a christmas tree
here look the purpose of this season is
that light always conquers darkness
there's going to be setbacks we saw that
in the petty act of uh unfortunate
fellow who did this but we don't let
that stop us god's way god's providence
always triumphs light conquers darkness
that's hanukkah that's christmas
hallelujah we need a little christmas
right this very moment all right
hallelujah and uh
after this can we baptize gutfeld i
am baptized bring them up only if we can
use eggnog
all right
all right steve ducey i know you have to
get to bed soon so
we'll make this quick
your thoughts on the ceremony
it's very nice i'm glad everybody was
able to come out tonight thank you very
much for showing up at fox square
tonight
we're not gonna let one guy with a
lighter ruin christmas yeah
ainsley
back up in 24 hours what a miracle i'm
just so happy to be here i'm so glad
that we're building it back and that so
many people have turned out when i
pulled up tonight i was just in awe of
all of our fans and people who have come
from all parts of the united states and
all over the world to come and celebrate
this night with us and you're right
we're not going to let a grinch steal
our christmas we're back we're better
than ever and god bless all of you
god bless
i think this crowd is bigger than the
crowd at the rockefeller tree
yeah do we have that right
all right it's a better looking crowd
because you're here greg absolutely all
right so abby take two right you guys
did a great job last week with the light
we're just gonna do it again
yeah i was saying earlier it's such a
blessing to be here because you know
it's rare that all of us get to be
together because everyone has different
schedules right i think we should take
the fox news christmas card tonight in
front of the tree um but yeah i mean
this guy lit the tree on fire but he
reignited the light in every single one
of us as we celebrate the holiday season
so it's great to be here and again we're
thankful to all of you guys back here
and everyone who showed up tonight all
right and we're
the number one number according to
artists in america
oh
mike rowe and mike's
mike's going to be joining us on the
five after this
but he wants more attention would you
like to say anything with your beautiful
voice mike you're too kind jesse but
look i was out here last night around uh
12 30. i don't know where you were but
you should have seen
the men with power washers and welders
working it was freezing cold talk about
a dirty job those guys got it done right
and they got it done first well said ask
him about the song he's saying on fox
and friends yesterday uh you know i'll
i'll do the emceeing here ducey this
isn't fox and friends all right let's
talk to one of these guys the chief here
first of all chief thank you so much the
response time was phenomenal how did you
guys do it so quickly
well thanks for having us and thanks for
acknowledging the good work that the
fdny and the men and women of the nypd
do day in and day out to protect the
citizens of this great city
thank you so much and no injuries
everybody's here looking very festive
janice anytime that i can wear a hat you
know i'm going to do so
but can i also say on behalf of the fdny
family i'm i'm married to a battalion
chief with the fdny thank you to your
service of course uh to all the police
officers here tonight we're so grateful
for your service and we're grateful for
your protection and and thank you all
merry christmas merry christmas
all right are you guys ready to get this
started
all right
before we get to that uh fdny engine 65
who responded to the scene yesterday was
supposed to join us tonight but can't be
here because they're responding to
another fire
so
are you guys ready to light it up or
what yeah
[Applause]
you're talking about the tree we're
talking about the tree greg
all right
you're so bad so
we're gonna push a button the burrow
commander is here so we're gonna start
it with a countdown all right here we go
ten
nine
eight
seven
six five
four
three
two
one
light
[Applause]
yay
it's beautiful
very nice it is stunning
[Music]
follow me in merry measure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
la
[Music]
special time to be here with all of you
tonight with all of the any thoughts
jessica and judge
well first of all i just think that the
tree is beautiful i'm thrilled that it's
bad back up and you know what we are as
happy as we were two days ago and we're
not gonna let anyone dab in our spirits
and jessica's here she her due date is
six days from now and so there's going
to be a wonderful christmas baby this
year this is like my christmas
it was great to hear the story also
about lifting the menorah on 9 11. i
only want one or two sets of presents
for that oh
well i'm gonna have my first christmas
tree ever actually right that's indeed
awesome
if we could all just do a round of
applause for our ceo suzanne scott who
led us in this and jay wallace president
of news thank you so much and for
everyone who helped make this happen
it's a very good looking tree please
enjoy some hot chocolate from jax torres
we appreciate you all coming out to see
this happen another big thank you to
everyone involved the hard-working
people helped get this done in record
time the american christmas company and
our lighting and technical crews the
religious leaders for their remarks but
not least we once again want to thank
the fdny and the nypd her heroes
thank you so much okay
greg's cold so we have to go inside
we're going to go back and do the rest
of the five stay tuned i'm steve ducey
i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis